mars detained opposition leader aung san
tsuchi has been handed a second criminal
charge which could see her held
indefinitely
without trial the former civilian leader
was deposed in a military coup
earlier this month today the un warned
the country's generals that the world
was
watching we're joined now by christine
schrainer bergener she's the united
nations special envoy on myanmar who
gave that warning to the generals
and who has been in contact with them
thank you very much for being with us
um so you've been speaking i gather to
so win the deputy commander-in-chief in
myanmar what did you say to him
well i said that they should refrain of
violence and that they should allow
peaceful assemblies and that we don't
want to see
uh breaking out of uh huge violence that
uh the coup uh was illegal and we want
to reverse the situation
and upholding the will of the the people
of myanmar
right and did he have anything to say to
you that reassured you
well i asked him if i can come
to myanmar as quickly as possible
normally i just go and we
arrange a time and then i have several
meetings on the ground
and i have a one year visa so i could go
but clearly
i want to go in this appropriate
conditions
and he said that they first want to
um continue with the interrogations of
the people especially
with dawan san tsuji uh she
had is now charged or to
have violated the communication law uh
because she
uh imported walkie-talkies
but also she was now charged to uh
for a violation of national disaster law
i heard today that she will have a next
court hearing on the first of march
so the answer from him was that uh they
won't
first have those interrogations and then
i should come
uh later but i pushed uh to
go as quickly as possible because um
it seems that i'm the breach between
all stakeholders yes absolutely and i
mean these are clearly trumped-up
charges
um in the past the military has launched
brutal crackdowns on protesters of
course do you fear
more violence to crush these protests
well i think they were are surprised
about the
the the huge uh support for the nld
government
and we don't uh we don't have the same
situation like in 1988
people have now uh social media they are
well organized and they are very
determined
to continue those protests despite the
the laws who
forbidding now the those protests
um so i hope that violence will not
break out
we have also a factor which is
uh quite important we have around
21 ethnic armed organizations in the
country
which uh told uh in a unity
that they are against this coup and they
don't like to see
violence uh on the street uh with uh
uh tamador the army who would use a
violence
so this is a i think an important uh
fact
for the the gover the the tamado
government yeah
to not use violence but um i gather you
said
a heavy-handed response would meet with
severe consequences
what would those severe consequences be
well i i see them going back to
isolation because
uh some countries already started to
implement sanctions
others will follow if they don't use now
this
window of opportunity where i can go
and find out what is the situation
how we can deal in
behind closed doors what i did in the
last three years
so if they don't take this chance
i'm sure that the member states of the
u.n will be hopefully
united in a response and
that they are collectively act to ensure
that the human rights are protected for
the people
right so you've spoken to the deputy
commander in chief
of myanmar have you managed to speak to
aung san tsuchi
no unfortunately not she's under house
arrest
uh but uh clearly i would like to speak
with her
yeah and i mean the this is clearly an
attempt to prevent her
standing in any future election um
do you fear for her in the future
well i fear that uh this can take a long
time which we
really don't want to see she already was
in
house arrest for 15 years and nobody
wants to go back in isolation and
don't want to see innocent people under
house arrest
and did did they promise there would be
an election
even though it's it's likely that the
world is going to think that that
election will be a sham
yeah they told me that they have a road
map uh the first is to
have a re-establishment of the union
election commission which
already started and
they want to continue
with preventive measure for the covet
pandemic and also they want to
have a peace process with a national
ceasefire agreement all over
the country and they want to have new
elections
in a in a year they said okay and just
30 seconds left do you believe
the generals when they say that to you
well i believe them because they they
normally
have a clear plan and they stick
normally to their plans
but new elections probably doesn't mean
that
all the parties are allowed to to run
that's my guess